В ефірі «heute journal» з
Ґундулою Ґаузе і Беттіною Шаустен.
Доброго вечора.
Президент США Джо Байден
під час свого першого візиту на Близький Схід
увечері приземлився у Саудівській Аравії.
Він летів прямо з Тель-Авіва,
що аж ніяк не є само собою зрозумілим,
як і майже все інше на Близькому Сході.
Цей візит був складною місією через попередні обставини:
Байден назвав саудівського кронпринца,
якого звинувачують у вбивстві журналіста Хашоґджі,
«негідником», проте все одно веде переговори із Саудівською Аравією
про нафту та інше.
Відчувається розчарування і
після вранішнього візиту Байдена до Палестини.
Докладніше - Міхаель Беверунґе.
Рукостискання неначе між старими друзями -
як знак відновлення дружби завдяки Джо Байдену
після свого попередника Дональда Трампа,
який значною мірою розірвав стосунки
з президентом Палестини Махмудом Аббасом
і скоротив велику частину допомоги США для палестинців.
Байден взяв на себе нові зобов’язання в доларах
на сотні мільйонів.
Політичні ініціативи - навряд чи.
Байден підкреслив свою прихильність
до рішення про мирне врегулювання конфлікту між Палестиною і Ізраїлем:
«Дві держави для двох народів».
Навіть якщо наразі ще не зовсім готове підґрунтя
для відновлення переговорів,
США та мій уряд не полишають надії
зблизити палестинців та ізраїльтян.
Це звучить як напускний оптимізм і не може задовольнити Аббаса.
Він хотів би побачити конкретні кроки, наприклад,
відновлення роботи консульства США у Східному Єрусалимі,
яке зачинив Трамп.
Під тиском Ізраїлю США відмовилися від цього плану.
Ключ до миру та безпеки
починається з визнання держави Палестина,
щоб народ Палестини
отримав свої законні права.
Але на вулицях Віфлеєму майже ніхто в це не вірить.
Інтерес до візиту Байдена невеликий.
Нечисленні громадяни прийшли висловити свій протест.
Сьогодні чорний день.
Байден навідується і «здає» нас євреям,
а ми все ще приймаємо і святкуємо його приїзд.
Однак у другій половині дня
Джо Байден уже залишив локальний Близькосхідний конфлікт
і переходить до глобального питання:
реорганізації архітектури безпеки всього Близького Сходу.
Ніщо не може так символічно проілюструвати це,
як його політ з Ізраїлю до Саудівської Аравії -
перший офіційний прямий рейс в історії двох країн.
Після десятиліть ворожнечі
Ізраїль тепер має повні права на польоти.
Приголомшливе зближення.
Завдяки спільному ворогові - Ірану - це стало можливим.
У разі екстреної необхідності Байден хоче застосувати силу,
щоб зупинити ядерний потенціал Ірану.
Після прибуття до Джедди Байден намагається
ще більше інтегрувати Саудівську Аравію
в ізраїльську антиіранську коаліцію
поряд з багатьма іншими арабськими державами.
Це - непросте завдання.
Саудівська Аравія є однією із ключових країн у цій ситуації,
що виглядає як пазл, до якого кожна
держава має робити свій внесок.
Але без сумніву цей пазл був би набагато кращим
із Саудівською Аравією, ніж без неї.
Ніби це було і так не досить складно, додався ще один аспект:
одного із найважливіших представників Саудівської Аравії
звати Мухаммед ібн Салман:
кронпринц, якому закидають відповідальність
за вбивство журналіста Хашоґджі.
Байден публічно назвав його «парія» - той, кого зневажають,
а тепер має вести з кронпринцем переговори про новий порядок.
Наш американський кореспондент
Ельмар Тевессен супроводжує візит президента
і зараз в прямому ефірі з Джедди.
Ельмаре, ми чули, що Байден кілька разів
називав Саудівську Аравію «державою-ізгоєм».
Що спонукало його туди поїхати?
Мова йде про новий порядок,
а також збільшення обсягів нафти для США?
Так, мова йде також і про нафту.
Але не тільки для США,
а загалом для всього світу у цій енергетичній кризі.
Зрештою також для Німеччини.
Джо Байден кілька хвилин тому виступив перед пресою,
але не зміг дати конкретної відповіді на питання,
чи насправді дійде до масштабного збільшення видобутку нафти.
Завтра це буде інтенсивно обговорюватися
на зустрічі країн Перської затоки.
Байден упевнений, що по багатьох пунктах
вдасться досягти єдності.
Найважливіше - Байден прагне створити союз
між Ізраїлем і арабськими державами
проти Ірану, який є головним ворогом у регіоні.
Також Байден хоче послабити
досить відчутний вплив Китаю у регіоні.
Байден пообіцяв обговорити і тему щодо прав людини.
Саудівська королівська родина
з великим задоволенням змогла використати його візит
як маркетинговий хід.
Ця світлина облетіла увесь світ -
вітання з кронпринцом.
Як багато довіри може втратити Байден через цю світлину?
Це коштуватиме йому досить багато довіри.
Вже на короткій пресконференції
на Байдена тиснули щодо цього, зокрема з питаннями:
Як так може бути,  що Байден зустрічається з кронпринцом
і має з ним спільні справи.
Водночас Джо Байден намагається пояснити,
чому все саме так.
У Білому домі довго сперечалися,
чи варто зустрічатися з Мухаммедом ібн Салманом,
і дійшли до висновку, що цієї зустрічі не уникнути.
Без ібн Салмана, який в майбутньому очолить Саудівську Аравію,
не буде дружби між Саудівською Аравією та Ізраїлем,
не буде потужного фронту проти Ірану
і послаблення впливу Китаю.
Тому Байден говорить з ібн Салманом,
але водночас має зачепити і тему
порушення прав людини і громадян в Саудівській Аравії.
В цьому контексті варто згадати і тему,
яку ми зараз також обговорюємо
щодо відносин Заходу з Росією і Китаєм.
Чим керується зовнішня політика:
мораллю чи економічними інтересами?
Складне питання також і на цій зустрічі.
Безумовно, це в основному показує відсутність поняття
чорного і білого.
Є тільки відтінки сірого.
Союз із Саудівською Аравією – це, мабуть, найменше з двох лих,
коли очевидно, що Китай і Росія
хочуть подальшого розширення авторитаризму.
Також тут, в регіоні, за останні місяці високопосадовці
з п'яти країн Перської затоки здійснили поїздки до Китаю,
щоб заручитися підтримкою в галузі технологій, інфраструктури.
Вони воліли б робити це з Америкою,
а також мати її захист у військовому плані.
Це шанс для Сполучених Штатів,
яким би вони хотіли скористатися.
Тоді США мали б важелі вимагати конкретних зобов’язань
щодо дотримання громадянських прав і прав людини у регіоні.
Якщо Байден цього не вимагатиме, він втратить довіру.
Повертаємося до Німеччини.
Літо в країні вже не таке, як було раніше.
Бажанню німців безтурботно відпочити на півдні
постійно щось перешкоджає:
проблеми з авіакомпаніями, хвилі спеки, пожежі,
до усього додався і коронавірус.
Насувається літня хвиля коронавірусу
і псує багатьом омріяне літо без обмежень,
пов'язаних з пандемією.
Міністр охорони здоров’я рекомендує людям до 60 років
зробити четверте щеплення.
Це найкращий варіант,
як запобігти ризику зараження цього літа.
Поки що рекомендації ЄС і Постійної комісії з вакцинації STIKO
не передбачають такого,
тому Карл Лаутербах знову вносить плутанину.
Прямо з Берліну - Зімон Пфанцельт.
Рідко коли страх перед зимою
так сильно визначав політику літа, як цього року.
Те, як Німеччина переживе холодну пору року,
стосується не лише газу, а й пандемії.
Четверте щеплення і для молодших осіб,
для осіб до 60 років, є рішенням,
яке запропонував міністр охорони здоров’я,
щоб принаймні перервати нинішню хвилю ще до початку осені.
Це може бути дуже доцільним рішенням,
тому що тоді ризик інфікування
вже з самого спочатку буде меншим.
І якщо ви все-таки інфікуєтесь,
ризик лонгковіду також буде нижчим.
Пропозиція Лаутербаха не нова.
Але питання щодо четвертого щеплення
зараз набуває особливої актуальності.
Літня хвиля коронавірусу цього року - безпрецедентна,
захворюваність висока,
кількість незареєстрованих випадків, напевно, така ж висока.
Це підживлює страх перед ще гіршою ситуацією восени.
На сьогодні у реанімаціях у нас 1218 хворих.
Це на сотню більше, ніж тиждень тому,
втричі більше, ніж рік тому,
і вп’ятеро більше, ніж два роки тому влітку.
Тому ситуація напружена.
Три чверті важкохворих пацієнтів старше 60 років.
Це ще одна причина, чому вакцинація для молодших осіб - суперечлива.
Постійна комісія з вакцинації STIKO,
яка фактично є відповідальною за рішення щодо вакцинації,
явно суперечить міністру охорони здоров’я.
Немає даних, які виправдовують поради Лаутербаха,
сказав очільник STIKO Томас Мертенс:
«Я вважаю, що це погано,
давати медичні рекомендації за принципом «що більше, то краще».
Комісія рекомендує вакцинувати вчетверте лише тих,
кому за 70 років і осіб з груп ризику.
Але Лаутербах не хоче знати про існування суперечностей.
Мертенс зазначив, що немає досліджень серед людей
молодше 60 років, які б, наприклад,
показали нижчий рівень смертності.
З цим ніхто не сперечається.
Це так, але як було показано для всіх вікових груп,
включаючи тих, кому до 60 років,
ті, хто зробив четверте щеплення,
інфікуються не так швидко.
Часове планування міністра охорони здоров’я дивує,
принаймні, на перший погляд.
Насправді його міністерство обіцяє до вересня нові вакцини,
адаптовані до різних штамів вірусу.
Заглибившись в деталі стає зрозуміло, що цей графік досить хиткий.
Проблема з адаптованими вакцинами полягає в тому,
що ми не знаємо точно, коли вони з'являться.
По-друге, вони адаптовані
під оригінальний варіант штаму «Омікрон».
Тобто під BA.1,
а не під BA.5,
який зараз поширений.
Страх перед зимою породжує більше запитань,
ніж відповідей.
Про інші важливі новини дня розповість Ґундула Ґаузе.
Офіцера Збройних сил Німеччини Франко А.
засудили до 5 років та 6 місяців
позбавлення волі.
Вищий земельний суд Франкфурта-на-Майні
визнав його винним у підготовці серйозного злочину,
що становить небезпеку для держави.
Підозра у тероризмі обґрунтована.
Він діяв з ультраправих екстремістських мотивів.
33-річний чоловік планував напади
на політиків та високопосадовців.
Протягом кількох місяців він видавав себе
за сирійського біженця
і вів подвійне життя.
Захист оголосив про подання апеляції.
У Мюнстері було порушено кримінальне
та дисциплінарне провадження
проти групи правоохоронців,
що поширювали у своєму листуванні можливі
ультраправі екстремістські погляди.
За даними, сім чинних та один колишній член
спецпідрозділів швидкого реагування Німеччини (SEK),
обмінювалися фотографіями та відео
екстремістського змісту.
Міністр внутрішніх справ землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
Герберт Ройль
як найвищий керівник поліції підкреслив,
що політика нульової толерантності
діє і щодо самих правоохоронців.
Міністр праці та соціальної політики Німеччини
Губертус Гайль
планує підвищити розмір державних виплат по безробіттю Hartz IV
з наступного року через значне зростання цін.
В інтерв'ю виданню «Redaktionsnetzwerk Deutschland»
міністр також заявив,
що через високу інфляцію фінансову допомогу від держави
мають отримувати лише люди з низьким
та середнім рівнем доходів.
Підтримали пропозицію профспілки, громадські об'єднання
та політики з партії Зелених,
проти виступила партія FDP.
Державна Дума ухвалила закони,
що дозволяють переведення економіки Росії
на військові рейки.
Крім того, у Москві оголосили про скликання
подальших позачергових засідань Державної думи.
Щодо російського обстрілу ракетами Вінниці
сторони надають різні дані, які неможливо перевірити.
За даними Міністерства оборони Росії,
вразили військовий об'єкт.
За даними української сторони, ракети влучили
в цивільні об'єкти.
Кількість загиблих зросла до 23.
Республіка Молдова, країна-сусід України,
страждає від наслідків війни:
сотні тисячі біженців прибувають до бідної країни.
Щоб пом’якшити навантаження на економіку Молдови,
світова спільнота планує
надати Республіці Молдова фінансову допомогу
сумою 600 мільйонів євро.
Міністерка закордонних справ Німеччини Анналена Бербок,
як співголова Міжнародної донорської конференції
в Бухаресті,
заявила, що Німеччина планує надати Молдові 77 млн євро.
Ці гроші підуть на допомогу біженцям та на пом'якшення
наслідків значного підвищення цін на енергоносії.
Рік після катастрофічної повені в Німеччині.
Вчора ми розповідали про річницю цієї трагедії
в землях Рейнланд-Пфальц та Північний Рейн-Вестфалія.
У місті Штольберг, у районі Ахен, 15 липня минулого року
над прірвою свого існування опинилися багато людей,
але і багато підприємств,
зокрема сімейне підприємство «Prym».
Воно спеціалізується на виготовленні ґудзиків, якість яких
відома у всьому світі.
Але останній рік змусив компанію
мобілізувати всі її ресурси.
Це була запекла боротьба.
Детальніше розповість і покаже Ральф Гольдман.
Потужності виробництва знову задіяні майже на 100%.
Тут, наприклад, виробляють ґудзики для дитячих комбінезонів -
на підприємстві «Prym» у місті Штольберг, район Ахен.
Керівник підприємства Аксель Віртмюллер
ніколи не втрачав надії.
Я завжди твердо вірив, що колись я знову стоятиму тут,
і ми зможемо відновити виробництво, як зараз.
Але того дня неможливо було уявити,
що сталося насправді.
І цього не очікував ніхто.
Того дня рік тому
невелика річка Фіхт затопила всю будівлю підприємства.
Шафи з сусіднього підприємства змилися до підвалу.
Вночі пожежники вивели персонал із будівлі.
Вже тоді в Акселя Віртмюллера
з'явився бойовий запал.
У будь-якому разі, не лише керівництво, а й сім'я,
чітко воліють продовжувати тут працювати,
відбудовувати та відновлювати виробництво.
І ми намагаємося це зробити, об'єднавши наші зусилля.
Підприємство «Prym» неначе використало кризу
як можливість.
Підприємство має інструкції щодо дій
у разі виникнення аварійної ситуації,
оскільки тут зберігають хімікати.
Під час відбудування вони мали дотримуватися
певних вимог.
Підвал тепер виблискує по-новому,
вікна, що виходять на вулицю, замурували,
всюди встановили захисне устаткування від повеней.
Страхова компанія покриває витрати
на відбудову і збитки від простою виробництва,
сума яких становить приблизно 20 мільйонів євро.
Я знаю про підприємства, які не були застраховані.
Я також знаю підприємства
і багатьох приватних підприємців,
де справи йдуть не так добре.
Ми справді можемо радіти,
що маємо страхового партнера,
який загалом з нами дуже плідно працює.
Торгово-промислова палата Німеччини
надає підтримку підприємствам,
які звертаються за допомогою.
Лише на заході землі Північний Рейн-Вестфалія
від повені постраждали 2500 компаній:
великі промислові підприємства, середній бізнес
та підприємства роздрібної торгівлі.
Деяким підприємствам довелося закритися.
Пережити коронавірус і повінь вдалося не всім.
Деякі підприємці зовсім зникли.
Ми навіть не знаємо, де вони.
Ми писали їм безліч разів.
Це також частина цієї драми.
Але зараз ми не опікуємося цим,
а дивимося у майбутнє
і допомагаємо всім тим, хто займається відбудуванням.
Однак поглянувши на ці будівлі з вулиці Штольберга, очевидно,
що до нормального стану ще далеко.
Майже жодному підприємству не вдалося
поновити роботу.
Місто має починати все з початку.
Сімейному підприємству «Prym», схоже,
вдалося пережити це
завдяки витримці, значній солідарності
та страховій компанії,
яка також підтримує фінансуванням.
Іншим пощастило менше,
і можуть пройти роки, поки компанії впораються
з наслідками повені.
А зараз знову Ґундула Ґаузе з іншими новинами.
Європейська комісія подала кілька позовів до суду
на країну-члена ЄС - Угорщину.
Європейський суд має розглянути позов щодо повернення ліцензії на мовлення
радіомовнику «Klubradio»,
в ефірі якого часто критикують політику уряду.
Інший позов стосується дискримінації
гомосексуалістів в Угорщині.
На тлі багатьох криз фінансові ринки
очікують на нові економічні дані з Китаю
наприкінці цього тижня.
Відсоток економічного зростання Китаю
у другому кварталі майже не збільшився
порівняно з попереднім роком.
Валері Галлер, коли економіка Китаю слабшає,
це має величезні наслідки і для Німеччини.
Так, тому що Китайська Республіка, безумовно,
є найважливішим торговим партнером Німеччини.
Тому те, що немає прогресу в економічному зростанні,
не є гарною новиною
для Німеччини як країни-експортера.
Причиною погіршення економічної кон'юнктури -
політика «нульової терпимості» Китаю до COVID-19.
Але Пекін неухильно дотримується цього курсу.
Зачиняють цілі квартали, фабрики та магазини
за найменшого спалаху захворювання.
У портах накопичуються контейнери.
Наслідок - проблеми з поставками і нестача матеріалів.
Усе це має свою ціну.
У другому кварталі економіка Китаю
зросла на мізерні 0,4%, якщо порівняти з попереднім роком.
Це різке падіння,
бо ще у першому кварталі показник зростання
становив 4,8%.
Слабке економічне зростання
спричиняє хвилю обурення серед громадян.
Зростає рівень безробіття.
Водночас країна бореться з кризою у сфері нерухомості,
наслідки чого поширюються і на банки.
Зневірені клієнти банків
влаштовують демонстрації, як кілька днів тому
в місті з мільйонним населенням Чженчжоу.
Сотні тисяч клієнтів банків уже кілька місяців
не можуть отримати свої гроші.
Настрої в країні напружені.
Пекін намагається протидіяти цьому,
витрачаючи величезні суми на будівництво інфраструктури
для стимулювання економіки.
Багато експертів погоджуються,
що найефективнішою програмою стимулювання економіки
була б відмова від політики «нульової терпимості»
до COVID-19.
Але в Китаї на це навряд чи хтось розраховує.
На зв'язку була Валері з Франкфурта.
Дякую!
Південна Європа страждає від екстремальної спеки
та посухи.
На Атлантичному узбережжі Франції
приблизно тисяча пожежників нині борються
із надзвичайно сильними лісовими пожежами.
За даними місцевої влади, приблизно 7000 га землі
постраждали від пожежі.
Понад 10 000 людей довелося вивозити в безпечне місце.
Серед них - німецькі туристи.
Температура до 40° та вітер ускладнюють
роботу пожежників.
Спека дається взнаки й учасникам
велоперегонів «Тур де Франс».
За температури 35° південніше міста Ліон
13-й етап велоперегонів завершився черговим успіхом Данії.
У фінішному спринті Мадс Педерсен
випередив усіх суперників,
найшвидше подолавши дистанцію понад 190 кілометрів.
Його земляк Йонас Вінгегард
зберіг «жовту майку» лідера,
а берлінець Сімон Гешке вчетверте отримав
«горохову майку»,
що вже є рекордом Німеччини.
До Ерфуртського собору та церкви Сен-Северін
ведуть 70 крутих сходинок.
Унікальний архітектурний витвір
став неперевершеною сценою.
Фестиваль Домштуфен, що проводять на сходинках Ерфуртського собору Св. Марії,
розпочинається сьогодні ввечері
після дворічної перерви через коронавірус.
Це буде феєричне шоу.
Опера Джузеппе Верді, в якій ідеться про ізраїльтян,
що борються за свою свободу
проти вавилонського царя, є небувало актуальною цього року.
Опера «Набукко» - один з перших творів, що приніс
шалений успіх Джузеппе Верді,
і сьогодні в Ерфурті опера знову зачаровуватиме всіх.
У цьому переконана Даніела Зоннтаґ.
Він вважає себе найбільшим та єдиним
справжнім правителем.
Історія про царя Набукко, який хоче підкорити євреїв,
походить зі Старого Заповіту.
Перша успішна опера Верді зараз як ніколи актуальна.
Ерфуртська вистава сповнена очевидних порівнянь.
Спостерігаються значні паралелі
в агресії обох фігур.
Вони кажуть майже те саме:
я знищу вас усіх, я тут «хороший» і роблю все правильно.
Якщо проаналізувати все, що ми читаємо останнім часом,
паралелі досить помітні.
Паралелі та натхнення.
В Одесі люди співали
музичний фрагмент знаменитого хору рабів-іудеїв
з опери «Набукко» як гімн свободи,
в Ерфурті ця музика пролунала
на фоні українських національних кольорів.
Для співачки Валерії Мудрої ця опера як порятунок.
Вона - біженка з України
і отримала роль Фенени, дочки Набукко, яка повстає проти знищення.
Мистецтво і реальність.
Мої батьки живуть у Миколаєві,
сьогодні впало більше десяти бомб,
одна - поблизу будинку моєї матері.
Тепер я краще розумію цю оперу,
це так близько мені,
я розумію, наскільки цінне людське життя
і як важливо боротися за свою свободу, адже ви завжди переможете.
Меседж зрозуміли і глядачі генеральної репетиції.
Унаочнений зв'язок з Україною був чудовим.
Надзвичайно вражаючі костюми,
а також просто захоплюючий сюжет,
актуальність, яка не втрачається з роками, справді вражає.
Набукко проголошує себе богом
і божеволіє від цього.
У Верді деспот кається, демонструючи це відповідним жестом.
В цей момент на думку спадають такі поняття,
як толерантність, прийняття, великодушність,
визнання власної провини та, можливо, навернення до вірного шляху.
Набукко все це робить, і це правильно, але постає питання,
чи дозволяєте ви йому це.
Але, зрештою, пощади для диктатора немає.
Інсценізація «Набукко» на театральному фестивалі Домштуфен
у Ерфурті триватиме до 7 серпня.
Отож, лишається лише відвідати Ерфурт.
Боротьба за свободу як місток до випуску «Politbarometer».
Переважна більшість німців
виступає за продовження підтримки України,
незважаючи на зростання цін на енергоносії.
Детальніше про це розповість Маттіас Форнофф.
Добрий вечір, в ефірі «Politbarometer».
Чи перекриє Росія газовий кран?
Роботи з технічного обслуговування на газопроводі «Північний потік-1»
триватимуть до 21 липня.
Чи постачатиметься після цього газ?
Незначна більшість респондентів налаштована оптимістично.
Майже стільки ж сумніваються в тому,
що Росія продовжуватиме поставки газу.
Приблизно кожен третій вважає,
що Захід повинен посилити військову підтримку України
у війні, яка триває.
Це значно менше, ніж два тижні тому.
Одним із наслідків війни, який ми вже відчуваємо,
є стрімке зростання цін на енергоносії.
70% вважають, що ми повинні продовжувати підтримувати Україну,
навіть якщо ціни на енергоносії зростуть.
22% не хочуть цього.
Більшість «за» виявлена ​​серед прихильників усіх партій,
за винятком AfD.
Більшість німців готові прийняти обмеження,
щоб допомогти Україні,
але вони очікують значно більшої підтримки для цього.
Три чверті вважають,
що заходи федерального уряду
щодо полегшення життя громадян недостатні.
Війна в Україні, зростання цін,
загроза дефіциту газу взимку,
зростання захворюваності на коронавірус
викликають у людей невпевненість та стурбованість.
Загальне задоволення урядом і політикою знижується.
Майже усі політики з першої десятки
явно втрачають підтримку.
За шкалою від плюс п'ять до мінус п'яти
оцінюється симпатія та результативність політиків.
Політикиня Сара Ваґенкнехт знаходиться на останньому місці -
мінус 0,6 - результат трохи покращився.
Фрідріх Мерц - мінус 0,4 - трохи гірше.
На восьмому місці - Крістіан Лінднер з мінус 0,1,
і це найбільша втрата позицій.
Такий самий результат у Маркуса Зедера мінус 0,1.
На шостому місці - Карл Лаутербах з 0,4.
Далі Джем Оздемір з 0,8 - всі троє з погіршеним результатом.
Олаф Шольц опустився на четверте місце: 0,8 - значно гірше.
Третє місце посідає Губертус Гайль 0,9.
На другому місці - Анналена Бербок з 1,2.
Роберт Габек посідає перше місце з 1,6 - обоє значно гірше.
Лідери всіх партій
отримують погані оцінки.
Невдоволенню сприяло святкування
весілля міністра фінансів на Зюльті,
на якому були присутні знаменитості та політична еліта,
в той час, як громадяни повинні затягувати паски.
У Німеччині все більше несправедливого і нерівномірного,
кажуть майже дві третини респондентів,
і це значно більше ніж минулого року.
Якби в неділю відбулися вибори до Бундестагу,
то кількість голосів за SPD залишилась б незмінною - 21%.
Союз CDU/CSU отримав би 26%, мінус один.
Зелені досягли б 25%, FDP - 6%,
обидві партії без змін.
AfD - 11%,  плюс один.
Ліві - 5%, без змін.
Навряд чи Вам подобається це чути,
але пандемія коронавірусу не закінчилась.
Кількість інфікованих зростає,
у багатьох сферах через коронавірус - брак персоналу,
а в деяких клініках знову доводиться відкладати операції.
Тих, хто боїться за своє здоров'я, стає все більше.
Більшість вважає
теперішню ситуацію з коронавірусом проблематичною.
При цьому обмежень майже немає.
51% респондентів це подобається.
47% вважають, що це погано.
Найменше в цій групі
прихильників партій AfD і FDP.
Якщо температура впаде, а цифри продовжать зростати,
то восени нас чекає
ще одна хвиля коронавірусу з обмеженнями.
Наче цього недостатньо, так може ще й холодна квартира?
Федеральний уряд шукає вихід
і продовжує покладатися на електростанції,
які працюють на вугіллі, хоча б тимчасово,
навіть якщо вони шкідливі для клімату.
68% вважають це добре, 28% - погано.
Навіть серед прихильників Зелених
більшість виступає за такі заходи.
Війна в Україні та наслідки для нашої енергетичної безпеки
змушують нас відкинути деякі переконання.
Респонденти вважають, що охорона навколишнього середовища
та зміна енергетичної політики є
одними з найважливіших проблем у Німеччині.
Дві третини опитаних вважають,
що спека та посуха цього літа стали наслідками зміни клімату.
Для 30% температура - це нормальні погодні коливання.
Настрій на відпустку, хвилювання через війну,
коронавірус та нестачу енергії взаємопов'язані.
Дані «Politbarometer» це чітко показали.
Таким був наш випуск про настрої у країні.
Як завжди, графіки та всю інформацію про наші опитування
можна знайти в текстовій версії ZDF-Text зі сторінки 165,
у додатку «ZDFheute-App» та на сайті ZDFheute.de.
Проведення репрезентативних опитувань
дослідницької групи Wahlen,
інформацію про методологію і стандарти якості
можна знайти на politbarometer.zdf.de.
Дякуємо, що були з нами.
Наступний випуск «Politbarometer» дивіться 12 серпня.
Після погоди в ефірі «ZDF Comedy Sommer».
Приємного вечора, до побачення.
Добрий вечір.
Наближається невеликий циклон
з холодним фронтом та дощами,
який понизить температуру на узбережжі.
Потім прийде антициклон Юрген
і стане спекотно.
Сьогодні вночі дощ пройде на Північному морі,
а в другій половині ночі він переміститься далі на схід.
Також можлива невелика гроза.
На південь від північного Середньогір’я залишиться сухо.
Температура опуститься до 14-6°.
Найхолодніше буде у Верхньому Пфальці.
Завтра максимальна температура на морі
становитиме від 17 до 20°,
на інших територіях від 20 до 24°,
а в деяких частинах Баварії, Баден-Вюртемберга,
Гессена, Рейнланд-Пфальца та Саарланду - 25-29°.
Завтра вранці на сході
можуть пройти останні дощі та грози,
які потім швидко перемістяться на схід
із досить сильним північно-західним вітром.
На інших територіях дещо хмарно,
а найбільш сонячно між Верхнім Рейном і Карвенделем.
У неділю на півдні Німеччини буде сонячно
з температурою від 26 до 32°.
На півночі переважно хмарно, від 19 до 26°,
потім стане спекотніше.
У понеділок температура підніметься до 36°,
а у вівторок на заході - до 41°.
Це дуже суха спека.
Але, як можна побачити на прикладі міста Тріра,
після цього стає не так спекотно.
Гарних вихідних.